it is a new year but we've already seen
two deadly crashes on our roads and
several more just within the past week
the vigil was held tonight for a man who
died while crossing Boulder Highway
Madison Kimbrough joins us live after
speaking with his family about what
needs to be done to Madison stop this
from happening due to the lack of
crosswalks on Boulder Highway many
people choose to jaywalk here on the
highway and as you can see a vigil here
is for those who made that deadly
mistake including two recent hit and
runs happening just last week and on New
Year's Eve
at least you know a blinking light you
know for the pedestrians you know it and
it's so dark out here too Angela esqueda
mourning the loss of her husband of 18
years as She lays down flowers and
candles all decked out in red his
favorite color Manuela scada was trying
to get home on December 28th when he was
hit and killed while crossing Boulder
Highway near Russell outside a marked
crosswalk the driver took off 2022
traffic statistics from Metro show that
the total number of hit-and-run cases
have increased by over 35 percent from
2021 with pedestrian fatalities up by
over 7 for 2022 in their jurisdiction my
loving husband died right here and that
maybe it can save a life maybe they can
see it and no no don't jaywalk don't
cross for the other people dying to like
I just like you know like my mom said if
you know this Memorial will help anybody
you know this new story will help
anybody read think about their choices
of jaywalking it's dangerous
it's dark out here nobody can see you
you know and it just takes one time one
time to be hit and killed three days
later on the last night of 2022 a woman
was hit and killed in the same area her
death marking the 150 second traffic
related fatality in Metro's jurisdiction
for 2022. one more than a year before
you may recall the city of Henderson's
project reimagine which aims to increase
safety on Boulder Highway for
pedestrians and bicyclists now currently
they are in their pre-construction phase
with the city hoping to compete complete
it by 2025. reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now